it's a big big big big big piece ET can  confirm 25 year old rapper azealia banks  filed a police report Sunday against  actor russell crowe the two were  involved in an incident in a hotel suite  in beverly hills saturday night police  tell ET detectives are investigating  what went down this statement is from  Banks's team quote she is shell-shocked  and will speak out on the incident once  she has had time to process the  brutality and abuse she was unjustly  subjected to according to TMZ banks is  claiming crew called her the n-word and  spat on her before making her leave a  party at his suite but TMZ says  witnesses claim banks was making violent  threats so crow carried her out of the  suite and that at least one person says  it was banks who used the n-word not  crow et has reached out to the actors  rep for comment  you